we have updated vaccine polling data
from monmouth university we now know
that roughly one in five americans
still do not want the covet vaccine and
those numbers are
heavily and significantly led by
republicans 43
of whom still do not want the coveted
vaccine and do not plan to get it
if they can avoid it i guess that if
they can avoid it suggest
something about if it became a
requirement for a job or to do something
they want to do
maybe they would get it overall the good
news is that the number who don't want
the vaccine
is down but it's not really down
dramatically earlier in the pandemic we
saw significant reductions in vaccine
hesitancy it's really leveling out now
the numbers are stunningly partisan
if you look at numbers by party 43
percent of republicans do not want the
vaccine
22 percent of independents do not want
the vaccine
and just 5 percent of democrats do not
want the vaccine
uh if it were all democrats we would get
to herd immunity
if it were all independents we might
it would be 78 due and if it were up to
only republicans if everybody believed
what republicans believe
we would not get to herd immunity
although maybe eventually we would
because so many of them would get sick
that they develop natural immunity
that's a different story though
many would die in that process now also
interesting is that the racial gap seems
to almost have completely gone away at
least according to this poll
22 percent of whites and 20 percent of
people of color
don't want the vaccine that is now
essentially statistically equal there
was a point in time at which there was
more of a gap
led by vaccine hesitancy among the black
american
community so the big takeaway is
if 80 percent of the country plans to
get vaccinated
we can actually reach something
approximate approximating herd immunity
which medical science believes again it
depends on
how contagious is whatever variant
becomes dominant and
how uh sort of homogeneous versus
heterogeneous
is vaccination somewhere between 70
and 85 vaccination would be required to
achieve
heard however one thing we have to
remember
is that vaccine opposition is not
homogenous it varies greatly in
different parts of the country
the mississippi massachusetts gap
right now is a really good example 92
percent of those in massachusetts want
the vaccine
mississippi is already at the point
where tons of vaccination appointments
are going unfilled
demand is lagging so you could end up
with a situation where some states are
sort of
extra vaccinated well beyond what's
required for herd immunity
and other states never reach it and you
have constant small clusters and
outbreaks which will just
extend the pandemic the sad part is
that because some people don't develop
immunity even when you get vaccinated
remember it's a 95
effective vaccine some others can't get
the vaccine because of specific medical
conditions
you will have a situation where those
who could get it but just choose not to
will give the virus to some of the folks
who either got the vaccine but didn't
develop immunity
couldn't get the vaccine because of
medical condition and some of them will
die
that's that's the decision of anybody
who could get it and chooses not to
is that you are increasing the odds that
somebody dies as a result of your
actions
i'm glad i'm not participating in that
uh other information
from the poll approval for joe biden so
far is really looking pretty good 54
approval for biden remember that donald
trump never got to 50
approval even once during his presidency
62 approval for joe biden's handling of
the virus that's up from 57 percent in
march there was the idea that it was up
in march
but it's going to go down as biden uh
becomes the new normal
uh covet approval for biden continuing
to go up
for comparison biden at 62 trump was at
34
approval on kovid when he left office
and 63 percent approval for biden's
covet stimulus bill which was passed
last month so the numbers are looking
very solid for joe biden i think getting
infrastructure done would boost them a
little bit
but infrastructure is less visible to
the average person and it also
takes longer than just something gets
passed and then you get 1400 bucks
so the impact on approval may be maybe
lower one last thought
the pause going on right now on the
johnson and johnson vaccine which we
talked about earlier this week
it is giving a boost to the anti-vaxx
people
and it will be something that we will
have to wait and see the effect of
we see it impacting people anecdotally
saying well now i'm
definitely never getting any vaccine
uh seeing that on social media that
wasn't yet part of this polling
information so if we now see a reversal
and vaccine hesitancy goes up
it would be important to look at whether
the pause on the jnj vaccine
is a factor in that very interesting
news
even though joe biden has not said he
wants to
increase the number of justices on the
supreme court and is awaiting
a report about the supreme court
democrats
in the house and senate will be
introducing legislation
that would do exactly that it would
expand the number of seats on the court
from 9 to 13. many progressive groups
like it this is being led by congressman
jerry nadler
hank johnson monder jones uh
and in the senate senator ed markey
likes this same idea it is
way too early to know whether this has a
shot in
in the house i think listen without joe
biden clearly saying let's do this i
don't think there's any way in hell that
it passes the senate
uh but it is a very interesting step
that is going to be taken
i've said before i'm open
my general view is i am not that
into ideas that can be uh turned against
those who implement them and i've said
you know if you increase from 9 to 13
then the next time republicans have
control they could go from 13 to 17
and and that becomes sort of like a race
to the bottom and that doesn't seem
great we have a unique situation though
where republicans
to their credit i mean listen they
pulled it off but disgustingly
argued we don't put in new supreme court
justices during the last year of a
presidential term when barack obama
nominated merrick garland
and then with just weeks to go before an
election
uh in 2020 they pushed through the amy
uh
amy coney or amy kovet barrett um
nomination for donald trump to replace
ruth bader ginsburg
that to me passes a line where i believe
a threshold has been met
for a more um a sort of aggressive
action being needed so like i would be
okay with expanding the court i would be
worried about what the long-term impact
would be
we definitely need to be looking at term
limits on supreme court
justices so that it's simply
predetermined you know
i don't know exactly how the numbers
would work out but with nine justices
on the court that means that there is
one
and with you know imagine it's nine
justices 18-year terms
that means every six years there is a
retirement and a replacement and you
know ahead of time what the schedule of
that is
whatever the numbers would actually work
out to uh i believe that that's
something that would be
important to do and i very much support
that now
this bill when is joe biden going to
take a position on it
my thought from the beginning was joe
biden is deliberately
not taking a position in the lead up to
the election because it could be misused
one way or the other it's unclear what
the benefit would be
we were told joe biden would have a
group give him recommendations about
what to do with the supreme court
last week we learned no the group's not
actually going to give recommendations
it's just going to be
a report about the state of the
judiciary and and the court
so then the question is well who is
going to give joe biden recommendations
as to what to do and when is he going to
get those recommendations the way i see
it right now
is relatively cynical and it's this is
going to be a punt and you're not going
to hear
i mean he just he won't expand the court
he won't necessarily
say i am committed never to expanding
the chord
he will just say at this time i am not
expanding the chord i'm not moving to
expand the chord and that that will go
on and on that's my view um if you think
it'll go a different way
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
we have a fantastic show for you today
this will be the best friday show
in at least a week all right stay with
us we'll be right back
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
let's hear from some of our viewers
today now we're going to take some calls
via discord you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord now with i don't even know how
many people
are subscribed twelve thousand thirteen
thousand something like that
let's start today with josh from
toledo josh from toledo you are
on the air what's going on hey man
uh not much is going on just you know
finishing up
semesters at college uh
so i just want to pick your brain a
little bit
uh if you're okay with it you know i am
okay with it however
pick your brain that's like one of the
red flags at a dinner party if someone
ever says i want to pick your brain
i try to head for the hills because i'm
about to get into a horrible
conversation i'm going to assume that
because it's discord it's not going
south
no no not at all okay um
i just wanted to to get your opinion
a little bit on the problem of
misinformation
in the media and how to combat it yes
that's that's the whole that's the whole
question there was not a specific thing
uh hello yeah sorry i'm i'm trying to be
general here um i i apologize
well listen i've talked about
the source of a lot of this is we have
people
who reach adulthood and they fall for
this stuff
earlier this week tucker carlson did a
segment
where he simply said i mean this is just
it's so dumb but a lot of people fell
for it
tucker said um why do we need any covet
precautions
if the vaccines work maybe the fact that
we still have covet precautions is a
sign
that the vaccines don't work and
people are not maybe it's that they're
not confident enough to think for
themselves
maybe it's that they don't know how to
parse and interpret and analyze
such a media message but it's like the
answer is not enough people are
vaccinated yet it's really really simple
and the only way to really almost like
inoculate people from that
is you need to be teaching critical
thinking and media literacy much earlier
we're not doing it
it's not getting through people are
getting you know terrible messages about
how to think about things
from people they grow up around and
schools that are not working so well
and people in their family and facebook
and whatever else the case may be so
it's not
you know we there are things we can do
to try to fix media
but the real solution would be to fix
the viewing public so they don't fall
for this garbage
well i i completely agree with you on
that but do you think that there is
that there is some advantage in treating
the current media problem like trying to
break a cult
yes no no you you have to think it is
cult-like and we've talked to you
i have interviews where we talk to cult
experts and they talk about how
uh there is a cult-like element to
what's going on it should be treated
that way it's an accurate analogy
okay uh also i apologize if i'm bringing
up topics that you have
already covered a lot
no problem
yeah the i've been studying
this whole thing personally for
about a year now for one of my degrees
um and
listen yeah i i love it i'm gonna let
you go just because i have so many
people
waiting i appreciate the one question
let's look at a second question maybe
maybe next time
uh just because there are a lot of
people waiting to get on let's go
next to horus from denver
horus from denver you are on the air
hi david how you doing what's up
you tell me so i had a question um yeah
from something i saw on the bonus show
on thursday which i caught later
so i guess that's why i'm calling about
it now
um it's about that uh new utah they've
got
where it's like uh men pay fifty percent
of the pregnancy costs
yes and i wasn't totally sure what you
thought
about that rule that was the only thing
i couldn't glean from it
and then you know what your view of the
child support laws in general yeah so
um the story is one uh that that that's
being mentioned here that we talked
about on the bonus show earlier this
week where utah is moving forward with a
law
where the biological father in a
pregnancy
is responsible for 50 of the cost of the
pregnancy
and birth regardless of sort of like
relationship status or involvement with
the biological
mother and as i said on the bonus show
um i i like the idea
that responsibility should be shared
even though one of the two people who
are biologically the parents
are responsible for the actual birthing
and caring to term of the child the
concerns
include things like well uh if you have
a situation of
either you know domestic violence or
uh a child conceived through rape and
then you are
in theory sort of like tying a guy who
may not be a good guy who the mother may
not want
involved to the child and and what does
that do
but can we just deal with that by
keeping the financial responsibility
separate from something that goes beyond
that i mean i think that's the
complexity
i got that i got that i was just
curious what you make of the
i guess there's the argument out there
like should men have the obligation at
all to
be stuck financially too a child at all
and
that was the part i've always been
curious about well what do you think
should they
um i would
i kind of like what they do in sweden
which is they say you can opt out of
fatherhood now they have a robust social
safety net that allows for
you know enables that much better but
there's still the principle
there is still the principle yeah we do
not have that system here in the united
states
right you know that would enable it but
then there's separate from that as the
principle i happen to
be of the persuasion that it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense to
obligate him financially to do that and
uh
yeah does the mother have that same
choice could a mother who's pregnant say
i also don't want to have any financial
responsibility
she has the ability to abort she has all
kinds of options there
comparatively you have a lot fewer
options as a man and just kind of
you still have to be responsible though
in seeking out 1k
yeah we we seem to be on a delay and
yeah okay i'm going to let you go for
now the connection is aggressively bad
um i think there's a lot of issues there
uh wrapped up in that not not all of
which we are
uh necessarily able to get to right now
let's go to ricky from charlotte ricky
from charlotte you were on the air
david can you hear me all right i can
hear you fine
cool so i wanted to ask real quick about
florida
i think it's been a pretty big disaster
for the democrats past few election
cycles
and uh the way that i see it it looks
like desantis is gonna cruise to
his reelection um just the way things
stand right now
but i did see that the agriculture
commissioner of florida she's like the
only statewide elected democrat
overall she's a pretty generic um
imbibing type democrat but she is pretty
big on pro legalizing marijuana
and they're also trying to get a ballot
initiative for legalizing it in 2022
do you think if she if they tried to run
a campaign where
uh she is uh saying you know
vote for me and vote for legalizing weed
it pulls pretty well like over 60
percent which is what they need
yeah and you know if you elect me uh
we're going to implement it
quickly without restrictions the samples
would ruin it and all that do you think
that could
help them get him out office i think it
could i mean florida is such a strange
place in terms of its election dynamics
and then it also has
um you know the the the additional kind
of like x factor
of the cuban population of course most
voters from central and south america
vote mostly for democrats cubans are
the the primary exception to that you
also have a lot of
um folks who are you know we could say
they colloquially live in florida but
they may not vote in florida because
they only spend part of the year there
so sometimes even like the people you
see in florida and talk to aren't
necessarily florida voters
you also have the opposite people who
you would think are voting elsewhere but
are actually voting in florida
i i i think that there's a real
opportunity because we do see that
sometimes you see a dynamic in certain
states
where even though they're still voting
for a lot of republicans
on issues and on ballot initiatives and
on local races you start seeing them
move to
the left and it can be like a leading
indicator as to what is eventually going
to happen so
i like the idea that you're suggesting i
think trying to
um uh help the left by by
attaching a candidate potentially to a
ballot initiative
or issue based campaign is a really
great idea but i don't pretend to know
enough about the wackiness of florida
to be able to say for sure whether it
would be effect it would be successful
yeah i i hear what you're saying and you
know i
i just think that desantis especially
he's he's a big
political threat to the democrats i feel
like he's
uh a really good chance at being the
nominee in 24 without trump
so i think that if he lost his
re-election that would be a big
um you know that that would be a big
blow to
his nomination chances but you know
i don't i think you're probably thinking
of this idea that
you're you're not going to do well if
the last thing you did was lose a race
but look at joe biden joe biden
you know lost the primary in 2016
and then he won the primary and became
president you could say 2020 was an
outlier but i it's not that obvious to
me that
desantis he wasn't in the primary i
thought he didn't run
biden was not oh wait hold on my no
biden ran
no biden did run wait did biden not run
in 2016 now i don't even remember
no because his because uh uh because
beau died and he uh
because bo died like not long before the
election he said he like just wasn't
emotionally ready he was thinking about
oh yeah that's right what am i even
talking about
it's all good hey listen you know what
you may be you may be completely right
on desantis no i mean i think i
might the principle i think it's not
totally clear to me that a desantis loss
is the end for him for 2024. i just
think what's going the republican
anything could happen in the republican
party once trump won a republican
primary
it's sort of like all bets are off
anything could happen and we already saw
nikki haley say this week that if trump
runs she won't and she will support
trump
i think for the most part um people are
going to be deferring to trump in 2024.
yeah well the yeah i'm just desantis
just worries me because
i feel like he'd be a more effective
trump he's like if trump's fashionism
went to law school
right no i completely agree with him he
has all the same bad instincts and a
morality of trump but he's
more competent and more polished and
more polished yeah exactly
all right ricky thank you for the call i
appreciate it yep all right
there it is let's go next to lucas from
copenhagen
lucas you're on the air yeah can you
hear me yes i can
alright cool yeah i wanted to ask you
something about uh fiscal policy uh
especially right now with the new
administration
in the us so from what i can tell
the the spending of the biden
administration is just
blowing everything that the us has ever
spent really out of the water
and i've heard you talk a lot about how
the republicans all only say oh we care
about the debt but when they're in
charge
they don't care about the debt and i
fully get that but what is your
perspective on the debt
i mean are you are you not worried about
the
debt u.s is uh is amassing right now
so there's a couple different things
here um first of all
what when you look at the debt you have
to look at it relative to the size of
the economy
so the first the first principle is
just because the debt is going up in
terms of the number of dollars
i'm more concerned with what it looks
like relative to the size of the economy
if the economy keeps growing
and the debt grows proportionally i
don't see that
as a problem objectively that's number
one um
number two joe biden did the stimulus
package
and then there's some other things that
that imply spending via executive order
but
i mean you know the tax reform hasn't
passed
uh stimula i'm sorry infrastructure
hasn't passed so other than
covet stimulus what are you referring to
well i'm just thinking about the agenda
that some of the democrats are pushing
for um
i i get the sense that a lot of
democrats in the us want to
sort of transform the us into a social
democracy and european style
but um for example i live in denmark and
the minimum tax rate here is 37
income tax um and i don't know if they
have the guts to
to raise the taxes in proportion to the
spending that they're gonna do
so you it sounds like you're assuming
that taxes have to be raised
in relation to the spending they want to
do but that's not
necessarily the case but but the the
spending of the united states has really
increased a lot especially under obama
and under trump
so it actually relatively so the deficit
actually went down under obama it was
still positive which edged up the
national debt
trump did come in promising to pay off
the national debt in one term
he actually accelerated deficit growth i
think maybe
lucas the the the problem is you know
you started with wanting me to comment
on all the spending biden has done but
then when i pointed out
he's really only done covet stimulus he
said well there's a lot of democrats who
want to do spending which is a
completely different thing that hasn't
passed yet and they'll have to present
to us how
they will pay for the spending that they
want to do so we're kind of moving the
goal posts a little bit here
yeah but would you then be in favor of
something for example in germany they
they have a law that you're not allowed
to spend more than you earn
over two percent annually uh i mean i
get your argument but would you be in
favor of something like that i mean
you know i would i wouldn't and i'll
tell you why i'll tell you why i
wouldn't be in favor of that
there are types of deficit spending
that over the medium to long term are
deficit negative and are economically
stimulative
and they are often a lot of the
bigger projects that i think would be
important for
the country to do and so to to simply
arbitrarily say
you can't go two percent in spending
beyond revenues
when you might be able to do something
that would cost you net money
in the first or even second third year
but would be a big boon to the country
over the long term there's no i don't
see any reason to artificially
uh handicap the ability of our leaders
to to do things in that way i don't see
the benefit of it particularly the more
we learn about modern monetary
theory long term something will have to
be done right i mean you can't continue
on this path forever
i think you you understand that right i
totally get your point
it's not clear to me you know i mean
here's the thing not all economists
agree that we can't continue on this
path forever if
again if you look at our monetary theory
is really
something that that is highly
theoretical
and being pushed by some of the new
economists a lot of people disagree
many people disagree but understand that
many of the things that
neoclassical and keynesian economics
tell us
uh are only slightly older ideas and
they regularly fail to actually function
according to neoclassical and keynesian
economics
the u.s should should have seen over the
last 20 years
absolutely explosive inflation and it
hasn't happened why hasn't it happened
are you also going around saying
all of the neoclassical economists are
wrong
no i don't think so but for example uh
the
um interest rates have been very very
low yeah so it has been
it has been very cheap to take on debt
but i think now that we are
we are in so much that it becomes very
hard to push interest rates up again
to rates where we had them uh previously
of the financial crisis
okay and so what so then the inflation
will come when
i don't i don't know about inflation i'm
just a student i really don't know a lot
about
economics but what i do know is that the
us is
is uh taking on a lot of debt and so are
countries in europe and i just
i can't see why that would be healthy in
the absolute long term
yeah it's not um i get the idea
but you seem to be applying
sort of like household economics to
macro economies
and there's a lot of really good
academic scholarship about why
it's just the wrong paradigm through
which we should be thinking about it
well i would disagree but i think we're
short on time i bet you want to move on
so
i respect that well i mean you disagree
but you also said you're not really
you don't really know about economics
right well
i'm i'm gonna study economics i don't
really know
a lot about it yet but i think i'm just
sort of uh not really i'm not sure where
i stand yet
but uh some people say that that is very
dangerous some people say
we shouldn't worry about it um but then
well i think i think neither neither
view is right
that both of those are very black and
white views debt doesn't matter or debt
is very dangerous
what increasingly seems to be the case
is that we have to apply a more nuanced
view
and say taking on debt to do certain
things
and in certain cases is okay and then
simply increasing the money supply to
pay debt
maybe is not so good right so i think we
just have to look at things in
a more nuanced way
yeah maybe we should yeah but all right
lucas
thank you very much appreciate the call
let's take a very quick break
don't hang up if you're holding because
when we come back i'm going to go right
back
and talk to more people stand by the
david pakman show depends on the support
of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them we are taking calls
through the david pakman show discord
which you can find at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next to bethany
from oklahoma
bethany
oh can you hear me yes i can
perfect um i was wanting to talk about
gun control um because
i hear a lot of my liberal friends
talking about banning
um ar-15s and
um rifles like that but the truth is
that we don't actually have to ban them
and i only learned about this because of
my proximity to
the south essentially i live in oklahoma
but um
things like um full
fully automatic machine guns those are
actually
legal to get if you go through
um the process of getting a class three
weapon
and and um it's just something i think
progressives
should talk about more because like
silencers
those are class three weapons also
and so what people have to do to get
them is they have to
well off the top they have to pay like a
200
tax on top of what they were going to
pay but then they also have to
go through about a six month waiting
period um i think that might change from
state to state
but one of the most important things is
you have to meet with a police officer
and so you have to be interviewed and
they just ask you
you know what is your like plan for this
do you know what are you gonna use this
for and
yeah and i know people who have gone
through that process and it seems
it just seems like a really reasonable
process for someone to go through who's
getting an
ar-15 gun and i know that there's
there are lines blurred between what
hunting rifles are
and what you know the military-styled
weapons are and that's where the gun
industry does need to be held
accountable a little more
they probably need to um you know not
blur those lines as much
but overall i i feel like that is just
such a great compromise
that the two sides could come to because
i just i hear liberals just saying
ban them ban them ban them well what if
we kind of start with that narrative but
then we come to
well okay we won't ban them but let's
make them a class three weapon instead
i just don't hear that that narrative on
a large scale and i don't understand why
i don't know why either i mean i think
that it would make more sense to take a
sort of all-of-the-above approach
in terms of hoping to get something done
because you're not going to be able to
do everything you want to do at the same
time
if the left tried to work on all of
these angles at the same time
the right would just even further say
look at all of the different ways in
which they are trying to take away your
guns but i completely agree with you
that
there are things that can be done
without banning certain types of weapons
that may get us not not 99
of the way to the goal but maybe 75 or
80 percent
i think the other thing that also
sometimes the if we're if we're talking
about things maybe the left is missing
um the the the rifles
that are often used in mass shootings
are completely different from the
handguns that are involved
in the in what are actually the greatest
number of
gun related homicides and other deaths
which are
individual or one or two people are
injured or killed
and very often the left will sort of
talk about
the mass shootings and the individual
homicides and and suicides as if they
need to be dealt with
in the same way and and this allows the
right to very quickly say
you know when you give us the full
number of people killed by guns
when almost all of them are handguns and
all you talk about is assault weapons it
doesn't really make sense and they're
right about that and so i think that one
area where the left on guns could also
do significantly better
is better distinguishing that the mass
shootings and the guns used for those
are one
problem and then the individual and
two-person homicides and suicides
and the gun used there are a different
problem and they require different
solutions
yep i totally agree um yeah
i think that handguns and i don't i
don't know all the answers
uh for the handgun problem but i know a
lot of it deals with kids not having
access to them
um you know at such a young age and when
i read some article lately that was
talking about when parents are held more
accountable
for minors getting their hands on guns
and then
um you know tragedy resulting from that
um i guess holding parents accountable
can
can make a difference i i guess that
depends on the state i'm
i'm not exactly sure on all that but uh
yeah there's definitely work to be done
on that side and i
you're right i never really hear the
left talk about that either yeah
that's a great point all right bethany
thank you so much for the call
thank you all right take care let's go
next to um
audrey in georgia audrey and georgia
you're on the air
oh hi um i didn't expect
to be called um uh did you see
recently about the accidental shooting
involving a
uh a woman who meant to uh tase a woman
a man that um was being arrested
yes we covered that earlier this week
all right i wanted to ask your opinion
on something
uh what do you think should should be
the outcome for the police officer in
this situation do you think she should
be charged with manslaughter do you
think they should uh
simply bar her from police service and
let her off the hook what
what do you think it's not for me to say
she has been charged with second-degree
manslaughter i believe i i just read
uh yes yes and so it's it's going to be
up to a court to
to decide that my opinion about what the
outcome would be
was that she is not going to see a
guilty
criminal verdict in a court of law my
prediction was
on the criminal side it will probably
plead out and there will be a big
financial
settlement civilly that's my prediction
but i think that now that the second
degree manslaughter charges come forward
we we just have to let it you know it uh
i don't have all of the evidence i've
seen the video i've seen
commentary it you know we need to go
through the the process
yeah um i was talking about somebody
else earlier i think most people
can agree that this this was you know an
accident it's just
um now the thing about calling it an
accident i think that there's a better
way to say it
her intention did not appear to be to
shoot
the victim yeah whether we say that
that's an accident or we say
this is negligence by someone whose job
is supposed to be
to know do you have your taser or your
gun in your hand
we're talking about the same thing but
the implication of the words we use is
very different so for me you know when
we say
it was an accident versus we say it was
a negligent action by an officer
it's different and that's why i'm
careful about using that word
oh yeah of course thank you for
correcting me on that
um but what i'm
interested in is like uh the further
action that should be taken to prevent
these things from happening in the
future
yeah so um as uh we were talking about
this yesterday in
in this server and somebody pointed out
that the service weapons that they use
in the minnesota police force the
taser that they specifically use made by
axon
is extremely similar in shape
in color and in weight to their service
pistol
and um it doesn't surprise me learning
that that some
and i uh something like this would
happen
well you know there's another aspect let
me ask about another aspect maybe you
know this audrey maybe you don't
is it accurate that officers carry
their gun and taser on their
it's like the gun is always on one side
dominant versus non-dominant and the
taser is always on the opposite
um and i saw an interesting analysis of
this yeah
um i obviously i'm not a psychologist so
i don't
i don't know if this is true or not okay
but an analysis from a
police psychologist who had said that
under stressful situations
sometimes your motor cortex can um
can do the opposite action of what you
were actually commanding it to do
so that there could be a psychological
explanation for this
um i don't know the validity of that
yeah that i don't know about it
because it's coming from a police
psychologist right yeah no that that i
don't know about either listen i think
that
i am very comfortable having watched the
video and saying
the officer did not intend to shoot the
victim
but that to me does not tell me what i
need to know
in order to determine what should happen
in a
court of law and that's what the system
is now going to have to adjudicate
yeah personally i think she should be
um convicted of manslaughter simply for
the fact
that it imagined that there was
this was a minority and in this exact
same situation i believe that they would
be
convicted of manslaughter you're saying
a minority officer
uh yeah in a similar situation
okay i think that they would likely in a
court of law not be seen as fairly
as a white more privileged police
officer
got it i don't think that it would be
fair for them to get charged
and convicted and for somebody else not
to
okay very good audrey i appreciate it
all right thank you very much
all right uh let's see who else we can
we can hear from
today uh how about we speak to
um let's go to
tony from california tony from
california you're on the air
uh hello hello oh yeah i was in class
sorry um
i have a question uh regarding joe
manchin
sure last weekend when he was talking
about um
uh when he said that uh what was it um
he will now vote to eliminate or reform
the filibuster
right or uh we can sorry
yep and um i have mixed thoughts about
what he meant by weekend
okay such as um
maybe by um uh nuking the filibuster for
certain
types of legislation okay or just for
any type of
uh reform so i'm just wondering what you
think
about that i think at this point it's
very clear
that uh joe manchin is not willing to do
anything at all to change the filibuster
is the way i'm interpreting it
uh so for me i don't even find it
necessary to analyze
what would be on one side of the line
and on the other side of the line
i'm not getting the impression he's
willing to do anything
okay do you disagree
um i don't know i i really don't know um
i mean i've only been getting into
politics like
last year yeah so i i really don't know
anything i mean listen i get the
impression that at this point joe
manchin
knows that he has the potential to have
a lot of
negotiating power by being the guy that
might keep
uh joe biden from getting 50 votes and
keep him at 49.
i think he knows that i think he's
enjoying it and i think that uh
everything i hear from him including
recently saying
the january 6 riots made him realize
the importance of bipartisanship almost
like he's allowing the hostage takers to
to change his mind
um i'm very concerned by what i'm
hearing from from joe manchin
i can't imagine him being an ally on any
of the
the tough things on the easy things sure
he'll vote with democrats but i'm very
worried about mansion
yeah thank you my pleasure uh all right
thanks everybody who called in
we are going to go to a break we will
take calls again very soon and as always
i'm
sorry i was not able to get to everybody
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does all day
very very concerning to a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show
instagram account at david pakman show
okay
let's get into audience questions for
the week the first one this is actually
a really interesting question if
getting out the vote is a valid strategy
for winning elections why isn't
suppressing the vote a valid strategy we
are talking about two different things
here
saying to people you know what none of
these candidates really have your
interests in mind
if you vote for anyone you're
reinforcing some status quo
or you're enabling the two-party system
or whatever
even lying to people about the positions
of the candidates
in order to get them to dislike all of
them and stay home
you know that that's electioneering i
prefer people tell the truth but the
point is that
that is a strategy to say let's run a no
vote campaign or a blank vote campaign
or whatever the case may be that's the
opposite of get out the vote
trying to suppress turnout by
lying about polling places lying about
voter id rules
pushing voter purges looking to limit
early voting hours or mail-in voting
that is a completely different strategy
one is a strategy of disenfranchising
someone
from voting which is a right the other
is just making the case that it's not in
your interests to vote
and if if people don't understand the
difference between these two things
we're in uh we're we're in real trouble
now
i would disagree with the strategy of
forex i mean listen we saw this
there were lots of people saying i don't
like any there were bernie supporters
who when hillary won or when biden won
said
i don't like trump but i don't like
biden i don't like trump but i don't
like hillary i
i just i'm opting out i don't want to
participate i don't want to support any
of these candidates
i disagreed with them but that's that's
that's not voter suppression
that's saying i am making the decision
to wield my right to vote
by not voting or voting third party or
whatever the case may be
those are people with whom we would just
talk and figure out is that a good
strategy what is the goal what are you
trying to attain by doing that
will it actually work to attain that
there is nothing
similar when you then look at what the
republican party has done to try to
suppress the vote
trying to have absentee ballots thrown
out limiting who can get absentee
ballots
cutting sunday voting hours purging
people because they haven't voted in a
few elections by saying these are no
longer really active voters in the sense
that you should be registered
um voter polling intimidation that is
disenfranchisement
convincing people you are making the
country better by not voting
by choosing not to vote i would disagree
with the strategy i think it's always
better to vote
uh in every situation i've seen but
it is a completely different thing and
part of the problem
is that when people don't get it they
might be tricked by that question
they might hear hey you know what it's
true
if getting out the vote is a strategy
why isn't
suppressing the voter strategy well
suppressing
by just saying choose not to vote
protest with us
protest by not voting that's totally
legitimate
uh suppressing in the way that
republicans have been trying to do we
now have over 250 voter suppression
bills
across more than 40 states why because
they didn't suppress enough of the vote
to win in 2020.
it's quite that simple a very different
thing i'm i'm glad to answer the
question there is
very little comparison between the two
hey david with all of the talk of
vaccine passports
i'm wondering is a vaccine passport even
really a controversial thing
so no the answer is no i mean listen
the term vaccine passport is now being
used but what we're really talking about
is
to do certain things vaccination has
been required for a very long time
we're now talking about adding an
additional vaccination
but let's break it down to travel to
other countries
there have been vaccination requirements
for decades there are countries
in south america and in africa where you
need a yellow fever vaccine to go you
need to show proof
of yellow fever vaccination to go to
saudi arabia
i don't know if it's at any time or
during the hajj
you need to show proof of a
meningococcal
vaccine there's a list just look at
mandatory
vaccine travel requirements so there's
really no difference
in another country saying imagine france
there's two things france might do
france could say
everybody who lives in france must be
vaccinated that would be government
forcing a vaccination on people that's
not going to happen
france could say to travel here from
another country
non-french anybody who's not who doesn't
have a citizenship
right to be in france we require the
covet 19 vaccine they could do that
that wouldn't be new that wouldn't be
controversial it would only be new as it
applies specifically to the coronavirus
vaccine
we are seeing more and more colleges say
to be on campus in the fall
students will have to be vaccinated this
is not new this
is not controversial don jr has been uh
tweeting about
this as if it's some kind of dystopian
communist
authoritarian nightmare i know it makes
no sense his kids go to schools that
require certain vaccinations and
what some schools are doing is they are
choosing what is the list of required
vaccinations to come to
this school you don't have to go to that
school now let's
get to so now that we realize that what
we're talking about
is actually not new or particularly
controversial
let's go to what is being sometimes
implied by the term vaccine
passport um one thing that's being
implied is the us government will
require you to have a vaccine it's not
going to happen
it's just not going to happen and it's a
straw man this is sort of like when
someone says hey let's do universal
background checks
and the right says they're coming for
the second amendment they're going to
get rid of the second amendment
no that's not what's happening that
would have not what's happening at all
there's not going to be mandatory us
government i can't speak for every other
country
there may be some other authoritarian
countries that will mandate covet
vaccination the u.s is not going to
mandate covet vaccination
what you what you may see is different
businesses
say um we will require vaccination if
you want to do business with us
at a certain point you may see an
airline say we are beyond the period of
requiring a test
at this point if you want to fly with us
you need a vaccine
you may see certain sports teams or
leagues
say if you want to come after a certain
date we're going to wait until the
vaccine has been open to everyone for
three months
after that point which would be i guess
july 19th
if you want to come to a game at our
stadium you need to be vaccinated
i don't think it will be super common
but that would be
completely within the rights of
businesses to
do and a lot of the right wingers
opposing that are the same people that
for 20 years or 10 years or five years
have been saying businesses should be
able to do whatever they want as long as
it's not illegal it's not illegal to
require a vaccine
they will also there's another talking
point floating around which is
they are violating hipaa because they
are requiring you
to share medical information this is a
completely ridiculous interpretation of
what hipaa is
hipaa is something that medical
professionals are bound by
the business isn't forcing you to reveal
first of all hipaa doesn't apply
because it's you not a doctor's office
that would be sharing vaccination
information number two
you're not even being required to do it
it's here is what
we require if you as a participant in
the market choose to do business with us
terrible terrible argument now are there
arguments against
vaccine requirements generally this
isn't just about
covid uh sure sure um
you know if you have uh a situation
where there's really
inequitable access to a vaccine um
you could have a situation where what
you are saying is the poor
part of the world can't come to our
country
if we put in a vaccine mandate
and that's something that you could deal
with a friend imagine
in the imaginary france vaccine mandate
france might say
uh to come to our country if you're not
a french national of course
if you are in a country where
x percent of the population has already
been vaccinated then you need a vaccine
we will offer a test and quarantine
exemption
for people from countries that have not
yet reached 50
you could figure that out that's
something that you could figure out what
about people who can't get the vaccine
because of a condition that they have uh
where they are not able to get
vaccinated okay
that that's a now we're talking about a
practical issue that we can deal with
can you get a medical exemption from a
vaccine requirement that's also not new
that's something that's been around for
a very long time what countries
can choose not to offer though are
exemptions
for so-called religious beliefs and that
would be up to each each and every
country to decide so
long story short vaccine requirements
for travel
not new vaccine requirements for schools
not new the government of the us is not
going to force people to be vaccinated
and beyond that we're talking about
people participating in markets don't
like
the rule that a business has don't do
business with them no problem whatsoever
okay next question today um
does classical conservatism still exist
this is an interesting question
you know when we talk about classical
conservatism in the united states
understand that the idea of conservatism
the roots of conservatism
go back actually to the french
revolution when you had
uh conservatives who were often
french intellectuals saying they wanted
to sort of
go back to the previous
way that france was organized rather
than the post-revolution
france when we say classical
conservatism in the united states we're
talking
we're not talking about what things were
like pre-french revolution what were
my understanding is that conservatism is
basically talking about sort of like the
1950s
where uh you still had um
there was less awareness of and
opposition
to not only sometimes systemic but
actually codified racism
um out and out sort of glorification of
patriarchy
um even crony capitalism in some ways
where it was more open where maybe now
crony capitalism is in some sense more
more hidden
that that's what i understand as
classical conservatism being in the
united states and sometimes it's
presented as
we want so-called family values based on
the bible
as well as a low very low regulation
environment which
goes towards that crony capitalism thing
that i said
uh the the basic reality is that as it
is the idea of conservatism is a form of
sleight of hand
where what they're really talking about
is
classical conservatism in many cases is
limiting
the structures of power to
privileged groups whether it's men over
women
whether it's business elites over
workers
whether it's so so it's not just a class
analysis it's not just a race analysis
that's fundamentally though what we mean
by classical conservatism
it exists today in some
vestiges among
certain republicans it's funny because
the people that
trump calls rhinos republicans in name
only saying they're not really
republicans anymore that's kind of where
more classical conservatism still exists
it's people sort of like
mitt romney it's people i mean i hate to
say it
democratic senator joe manchin is kind
of like a 1950s
conservative in some ways they are
ostracized by the republican party now
because the republican party is no
longer about
the types of issues people like mitt
romney care about
even john mccain was sort of beyond what
classical 1950s
type conservatism was the republican
party has become about owning the libs
about rhetoric over substance um
about culture type issues divorced from
actual policy
even when you look at the more social
issues call
even calling them cultural issues
instead of socialism social issues is
interesting
before when it was you know gay marriage
abortion etc
it linked to policy in more of a direct
way
than a lot of these culture issues when
you talk to a lot of these republicans
who want to fight against cancel culture
and you say great what's the solution
there's often really no policy attached
to it because they will quickly realize
the policy that would come to mind would
be outrageously authoritarian
and supposedly against many of their
stated values
so does classical conservatism still
exist in the united states
to some degree it's increasingly on the
outs
uh within the republican party
it does exist but it is not
predominantly
what the republican party today
has decided to be in favor of keep
sending your questions in
i will keep answering them on every
friday show
we've got a great bonus show for you
today to get instant access just become
a member
at joinpackman.com